oh it smells like
oh it's nice I'm all turned around so
don't look at the state map this is my
second day in horror man stop
this has gone too far it has to stop
where is he
please help are we gonna help him no
we'll get through this
I know
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
will be my last of us episode 4 trailer
video there's a whole bunch of Easter
eggs and references we'll break it all
down if you're brand new to the channel
I'm doing videos for all the episodes be
sure to subscribe to get them we're also
doing a giveaway for HBO Max
subscriptions all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and post all
your theories from the trailer on the
comments careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on The Last
of Us so far if you haven't caught up
with the episodes but at the end of
episode 3 Joel and Ellie arrived at Bill
and Frank's in Lincoln just outside of
Boston a little while after they killed
themselves finding Bill's letter to Joel
giving him all his supplies his car that
they desperately needed to get them the
rest of the way to Wyoming the episode
in general was a big departure from the
video game story because they did so
much of Bill and Frank's backstory and
you didn't really get that in the games
but the end result of the episode was
pretty much the same but in the game
Bill really only gave them the car
itself and that was it in the episode
they got a ton of supplies including
LA's t-shirt from the games most of
everyone's costumes though and all the
props are based on versions of the game
but they are cheap changing where some
of the items actually came from and if
it wasn't clear in the episode Bill's
Car is meant to be the exact same
version of his car in the video game
like it looks exactly the same but
here's the next big change so in episode
4 there's a huge change from the video
games for that next part of the story in
the game the next major encounter
happens in Pittsburgh Philadelphia but
the showrunner and Neil druckman made it
sound like this next major fight that
they have in this trailer you see all
these scenes in the city is actually
Kansas City and it's against the hunters
who are a group from Pittsburgh in the
games it seems like they just wanted
them to move across the United States a
little bit more like they wanted the
city itself to feel much different in
Pittsburgh is relatively close to Boston
so on the show they will have gone way
further by the time that they encounter
the hunters one of the other big changes
is they've added a brand new character
that wasn't in the games played by
Melanie lynskey here who's named
Kathleen she's meant to be the leader of
the hunters now like I said the hunters
themselves are a huge group in the games
it is possible that they drive past
Pittsburgh in remark on it like there's
some sort of reference to that part of
the video game but a lot of what happens
in the trailer is part of their
encounter with the hunters in Pittsburgh
in the game so they are doing video game
stuff they're just changing the location
in a few of the characters the hunters
are an antagonistic group ruling Over
Pittsburgh in the game after they
overthrew fedra the governmental Force
there on the show it's going to be
Kansas City like I said and they are a
huge group they're meant to be like an
opposing faction to the fireflies making
The Walking Dead comparison again
because we're talking about characters
that are kind of like zombies but
they're being controlled by fungus in
The Last of Us the hunters would be kind
of like negan's group of Saviors
compared to Rick's group of the
survivors the hunters are meant to be
way more antagonistic but they're a huge
group like imagine if negan's group and
The Walking Dead started covering way
more cities the hunters when they
encounter them are meant to control this
entire city but later you find their
group has continued to spread across the
United States like they get bigger and
bigger and more powerful at the
beginning of the trailer they're camping
in the woods overnight Ellie gets
disgusted by the coffee is another
reference to her remarking that she's
never been in the woods been camping or
even been in a car for that matter so
everything they're doing on this mission
is just totally new to her and she's
worried about the fungus in general like
she's not totally Fearless there's this
sense of existential dread hanging over
everybody living in the apocalypse just
in general but just compared to Joel in
all their scenes you can tell she's
having way more fun at all this than he
is to him it's still more of an
obligation that he's fulfilling a
promise that he made to test to complete
the job so he's mostly doing this for
tests not so much for Ellie get her the
rest the way at least at this point in
their story he's not really doing it
because he cares about Ellie or anything
like that he's only protecting her
because he promised Tess to get her to
the other fireflies alive but Joel does
have that funny moment briefly with her
when she's complaining about the coffee
in the car talking about how it smells
and looks terrible slurping loudly just
to mess with her a little showing you
that he does actually have a sense of
humor it's just still so early in the
series in their story that will slowly
start to come out more by the finale as
they continue to drive across the
landscape we get wider shots of the
Midwest as they pass across the country
just showing you how nature slowly
started to take back the Earth even
though it's only been about 20 years the
reason why you don't see giant roving
bands of infected unlike The Walking
Dead with the Walkers is that the
infected aren't guaranteed to just keep
on living indefinitely as Joel and Tess
said previously in episodes a lot of
them die relatively soon for various
reasons before they can evolve into
higher States but the general rule of
thumb is that the infected will evolve
into higher States as long as they
continue to live the most dangerous one
from the game so far is the Rat King
like you've probably seen jokes about
the Rat King even if you haven't played
the games which is what they call the
infected who's lived for over 20 years
and becomes this hybrid amalgamation of
a bunch of different types of infected
like a super fungus Warrior within the
context of The Last of Us the fireflies
consider it something of an anomaly like
nobody truly understands exactly how the
fungus works at that stage of
development but the idea is that the Rat
King has this whole bunch of extra
weapons and armor growing around its
body because it's continued to evolve so
so much and because it's meant to be the
fusion of a couple different types of
infected that'll kind of bond and grow
together it's way way bigger maybe maybe
we'll see a rat king in like season two
or season three then in the trailer
Ellie gets them lost they start yelling
at each other because she's never been
outside the quarantine Zone she's never
tried to read a map like this naturally
she's not going to be a dynamite
navigator on her first try they get lost
in Kansas City like in the actual City
they slam on the brakes to avoid hitting
someone calling for help and this is a
scene taken directly from the games but
it's happening in Pittsburgh in the
games it is part of the way the hunters
lay traps for unsuspecting guests luring
people who they refer to as tourists
like people who aren't part of their
group already into a false sense of
security helping the helpless and
praying on their Goodwill but Joel
correctly smartly tells Ellie they're
not going to help him which is super
smart on his part it's not him being an
[__] it's just that paranoia like the
joke that they referenced in episode
three where he's talking to bill in the
flashbacks oh I'm just like you we're
extra careful in situations like this
but here in this moment the wheels are
turning in Joel's head and he's thinking
this is the way that I would play it if
I were trying to trap people and that's
why they try to bail on it the Hunter's
group generally kills anybody they can
find like shoot first ask questions
later even on their truck here it says
run and spray paint on the front kind of
mocking the people that they mow down
with it basically anybody that travels
into their City Kansas City in this case
in the TV show the hunters will kill and
they just try to take all their stuff
and Joel and Ellie rolled in with a
truck full of supplies in a big part of
Joel and Ellie's story during the next
part during episode 4 episode 5 and
Beyond is then bonding Mortons appear
while they're busy trying to escape the
hunters across the city like they're
literally finding their way across the
city and they also use those moments for
Joel to start answering more of Ellie's
questions that she keeps badgering him
with they kind of had some of that
energy in episode 3 couple scenes where
they're walking down the road and she
kept asking him about his history just
being really inquisitive there are way
more moments like that in episode four
the only difference is that in the last
episode he was still very reluctant
didn't fully answer a lot of the
questions or answered very quickly or
was vague about some of his answers in
episode 4 he starts to open up to her
more in the sheer trauma of what they go
through trying to escape the hunters and
all their heartfelt chats as they're
running from all the bullets brings them
much closer together ultimately the
scene of Joel getting stuck in the
traffic jam on the highway is earlier in
the episode before they make it into the
City and it's the whole reason why they
have to go into the city instead of just
using the highway because back in 2003
when things went crazy with the fungus
everyone started turning you had all
these people driving around at the time
which led to a bunch of pileups on the
highway making portions of the highway
system unusable in present day we get
the scene of Melanie lynskey's Kathleen
leader of the hunters holding someone
captive another new character when he
says this has to stop it's gone too far
and she asks him where they are I'm
assuming she's talking about Joel and
Ellie and it's happening later in the
episode there's a couple fight scenes of
them running through the buildings
Escaping The Hunters trying to kill them
and I believe the next two episodes will
be here around this location in Kansas
City around the Hunters episode 4 and
episode 5 because there are a couple of
big characters in the game that we've
seen in the trailers they encounter in
this same larger encounter against the
hunters so they've confirmed that
they're going to be characters on the
show I'm assuming that happens
relatively soon after the events of this
particular episode like it'll be the
next episode after this no spoilers for
what's going on with their story we'll
just wait till they drop the episode 5
trailer to talk about them I don't know
if Melanie olinsky is supposed to be in
multiple episodes because she has a
brand new character that wasn't in the
games and in the games after they make
it through the hunters portion of the
story at least in the first game you
only hear about the hunters briefly but
they are still a huge antagonistic
faction looming in the background and a
big rival to the fireflies the group
continues to get bigger and spread
through other cities in the United
States getting larger controlling more
territory and in the second game last of
us do they encounter another separate
group of hunters eventually so because
they just confirmed season two is going
to be adapting The Last of Us two are
part of last of us through the going to
break the second game into a couple
different seasons I wouldn't be
surprised if they keep Melanie lynskey's
character around longer term in future
Seasons but we'll see they've already
been changing a lot of stuff from the
game so we'll see how they continue to
change stuff on the show but there are
so many huge actors that show up on this
show we've only had three episodes but
they're like a couple really big actors
that only came for a couple episodes
there is some other footage from
previous trailers with Ella using Bill's
Gun while they're running through the
streets I'm assuming this is from
episode four two and they're still in
Kansas City against the hunters and it's
just the show not waiting long to pay
off the scene of her finding a gun after
asking Joel and Tess for once so many
times like oh I found a gun this will
come in handy and then boom next episode
it comes in real Handy a lot of her Arc
especially early in the game here is
experiencing things for the first time
actually literally says both cool stuff
and experiencing traumatic stuff for the
first time one of them is actually
having to kill a regular person for the
first time she's killed infected before
she met Joel she was traumatized by that
and we'll see that in future flashbacks
but up to this point she's never
actually had to kill a regular person
that was not infected like these Hunter
characters and it's just another step on
her path to toughening up and learning
to survive on her own she's not
completely helpless but as you see in
the trailer so far in all the episodes
she can barely read a map so she has a
long way to go before she could survive
completely on her own long term if you
spotted any other Easter eggs or
references in the trailer that I didn't
mention in the video write them Below in
the comments my full Last of Us episode
4 video will post Sunday after they
release it there was a brand new
Mandalorian season 3 trailer I'm working
on a new video for that it is a real big
thing that's happening right after I'm
posting this video is James Gunn is
meant to announce his new DC Phase One
slate of movies in the new Superman
movie like all the big rebooted DC
movies of course I'll do videos for all
the stuff that he announces make sure
you have alerts enabled for my channel
so you don't miss any of those
congratulations space invader you're the
giveaway winner from my last Last of Us
episode video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details everyone click here
for my full Last of Us episode 3 video
in Easter eggs and click here for all my
last of us episodes thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe